so you take your 1 point now I've got
the single loop so I've just got it on
one finger and I'm often going to be
just holding it like this but maybe
you've got like a ball and then you just
hold it like that
maybe you've got your double loop in
which case you just put them on backs of
your fingers what I want you to do at
first it's just them say we're facing
this way together we're gonna turn this
way so we're both facing this way and I
think I want you to just swing the poi
just feel feel its weight and imagine
that the weight is uh it's a big mouse
there's a mouse sleeping in the end of
your poi you'll notice you're swinging
along past your right foot and it's like
you're on a train track a little bit so
your swing is front and back along this
this imaginary train track which we can
call the plane of movement now if you
want you can switch and do it on the
other side on the other train track it's
still my right arm but now it's on the
other track so he can switch you're on
the one track and you're on the other
track right you can switch back and
forth you can also just switch hands
Boop and again it's a sleeping Mouse so
you're trying to feel what's really
going on and you can start to loosen up
into that and even start letting your
feet move around so then from the swing
motion you can swing the poi into
circles you can swing it into spinning
forwards and then you go back to
swinging or you can go into spinning
backwards and the other hand I can spin
backwards go back to swinging and I can
spin forwards now for you those
transitions might be a little less
smooth maybe for you right now if you go
to switch directions it goes to floppy
flop alright and that's okay you'll just
develop the
muscle memory and develop the you know
whatever has to slowly develop in your
brain to let that be really smooth it
won't be smooth from day one necessarily
and eventually you've got backward
circle swing forward circle swing
backward circles swing forward circle
swing then you can do this come to back
to set your right hand got the play get
it spinning forwards so it's want you to
notice the feeling of that okay is it
spinning forwards or backwards so you
can test if it's spinning forwards it's
gonna get you in the feet and so if the
pie hits you where it's gonna hit you if
it's coming down in front hits you the
feet that's forwards if it's spinning
backwards it'll hit you in the shoulder
or the head if it hit you so yeah get a
feeling for the both kind of feeling
backwards and see how you can throw it
over your shoulder forwards you can hit
your foot backwards you can go over the
shoulder the head fours and hits the
foot now as you get it going forwards
pay a little attention to what are you
really doing with your hand with time
I'm gonna be encouraging you to always
be opening the moving up more and more
so that your fingers are involved your
wrists this involved a little bit your
elbow that the movement is through as
much of your body as possible as opposed
to a lot of people they just at first
they just kind of bounce up and down or
they do something a bit stiff you want
to loosen up so your hands really making
like give a little pencil and you're
drawing a circle and often the poi will
seem to want to bend in a way that
you're not you know it'll bend inwards
or it'll go it'll tilt like this and
it'll take time to learn to control that
and the way to control it is just
learning to bend it on purpose
so on purpose you could say let it go to
the left right and then try to bring it
back and you think I'm trying to whack
that float or I let it drift towards the
camera and then back
towards the camera over there and then
you see it's like you have this bicycle
wheel you can turn the bicycle wheel to
the left
bicycle wheel to the right bicycle wheel
left bicycle wheel to the right this is
very different than crossing the POIs I
decide this is bending the plane and I
can also bend the plane to the sky or I
can try bending the plane to the ground
so by playing with that you will develop
the skill of deciding whether you want
the plans to stay on a track or whether
you you want to bend manipulate your
plans so forwards and backwards with
each hand I want you to put time into
playing with your planes let's go left
and backwards now and seeing how you can
manipulate those planes and it might be
kind of awkward to do it first it won't
quite do what you want so you just need
to experiment and slowly it will start
to work the helicopter and then try to
get it back to backwards let it become a
helicopter back to backwards and then
keep looking what are you really doing
are your fingers moving is your wrist
moving and you know all that little bits
of muscles and ability to move them will
wake up and you will have more and more
control but will forgets week by week
and and you'll get better and better so
enjoy that and put time into it